Would you care for someone for sure have
to do just answer my questions with.
Okay.
A few years ago,
a friend and I went to the scientology
complex in Los Angeles to see what the
religion was all about.
We were curious.
I talked about it actually one of the
first episodes of the show.
We were touring around the facility,
introduced to some very nice members and
given personality tests.
The test,
which is officially called the Oxford
capacity analysis,
though it has no connection with Oxford
University or any accredited
institution,
was more intense than I thought it was
going to be.
An included about 200 questions.
A few of which are actually reproduced
exactly in this scene from Paul Thomas
Anderson.
20 12 film the master do linger in bus
stations for pleasure.
You muscles precedents for no reason to
past failures bother you.
Would you like to be told what to do?
Do you find interest in other people?
I often consumed my scientific usually
truthful to other unpredictable.
Yeah.
This processing scene from the master
is,
in my opinion,
one of the best sequences in one of the
best movies of the last 10 years.
It's simple,
brilliantly acted and hypnotic,
which is no mistake on the part of the
filmmakers if you're interested.
The scene offers some real insights into
how the religion of scientology
functions.
Though PT Anderson has always been
careful to say that the master is not an
exact retelling of scientology's
founding.
The similarities in character,
feeling and technique are hard to deny.
For example,
this scene,
the processing seen bears an
unmistakable resemblance to a vital
activity within scientology called
auditing.
The term auditing comes from a word
which means to listen in auditing.
The person running the session is called
the auditor.
The person receiving auditing is called
a pre clear because he has not yet been
cleared of his reactive mind.
In the master seen Lancaster Dod played
by Philip Seymour.
Hoffman is the auditor and Freddie
played by Joaquin Phoenix.
Is the pre clear like dod does here.
The auditor in scientology asks
questions of the pre clear with the goal
of reading him,
of Ngrams,
the term for traumatic memories stored
in what's called the reactive mind.
The auditor does this by helping the
preclearance relive the experience that
caused the trauma.
When the pre-cleared has a cognition or
a positive realization,
the session is completed.
If this seems a little like
psychoanalysis to you,
that's because it is.
When l Ron Hubbard,
the founder of scientology,
laid down these methods in his book
dianetics.
I think he genuinely believed that he
had devised a new kind of psychotherapy,
something that was scientifically
rigorous and effective.
Of course,
as we know,
dianetics is not scientifically
rigorous.
It has been repeatedly rejected by all
mental health communities as a
pseudoscience,
which it is,
but as we see in the master,
there's no doubt that the process of
auditing can cause and effect.
Where's your mother infringement back to
this time in the processing seen dod
gets ready to admit to a series of past
traumas including the death of his
father,
the institutionalization of his mother,
his incestuous relationship with an aunt
and the Times that he killed people in
war.
He uses these to access the primary end,
Graham of the session,
Freddy's abandonment of the love of his
life back home,
like in psychoanalysis dot achieves this
by talking,
by initiating and exchange that attempts
to unlock things that are repressed or
hard to face,
but the methods used are different as as
long been believed by.
It's critics.
Scientology auditing goes further than
psychoanalysis or talk therapy because
it utilizes a form of command.
GNOSIS.
Say Your name.
Say it again,
Freddy.
Well say it again.
Freddy quilt and again Friday.
Quell.
All throughout the dod works to bring
Freddy under his command and the first
part which is structured a lot like the
personality test.
He asks them a series of relatively
simple yes or no questions getting
freddy used to this call and response
pattern.
Utilizing repetition to induce a relaxed
and focused state.
In past failures bother you know,
do your past failures.
No.
Do you pass values bother you?
Do your past failures in life either you
repetition also signals toward important
status,
trying to get freddy to unconsciously
focus on his past failures.
After this brief mini session ends,
Freddy insists on more and data degrees,
but this time with the caveat that
Freddy can't blink or the round of
questioning,
we'll start again from the beginning.
This extra strain occupies Freddy's
conscious mind and with the priming from
the first part established,
he begins to answer the questions with
more openness and candor I've ever had
intercourse with someone inside your
family?
Yes.
Have you ever had intercourse with
someone inside your family had been
killed?
Anyone?
No.
Maybe not me.
Have you killed anyone?
Know How many times did you have
intercourse with your hand?
Three times,
whereas no.
I don't know what you'd like to have
intercourse with her.
Again,
with the patterns set dot increases the
intensity and increases the intensity
and increases the intensity to such a
pitch that freddy is visibly tensing up.
Then at the most charged moment,
dot breaks the pattern and asks,
ready to close his eyes.
The emotion of this moment is real
dislike.
Hypnosis is real.
Just like psychotherapy and
psychoanalysis are real.
Let's because cognitive activity is
real.
It can be harnessed and manipulated and
projected and seen from new angles.
Auditing is at the center of Scientology
because it can produce these feelings of
epiphany that convinced people that the
methods which achieve it must be
correct.
That's the danger of scientology to mean
hypnotherapy is a valid form of
treatment for those who want to seek it
out,
but scientology flatly denies that
auditing utilizes any hypnosis at all,
so the people like Freddy,
who experienced it unknowingly are
susceptible to coercive suggestion.
Whether it's done maliciously or by
someone not properly trained.
It can be persuaded to believe that the
church is right with a capital r and
thus deserves all the time and money
they're asked.
To give it.
To make it clear all you have to do a
show fellow that he's mocking up his own
mind,
bear for his own difficulties,
and that he is not a completely adrift
in am swamped by a body,
and there he is.
You've got to clear.
Hubbard held that auditing like we see
in the master was the way to quote
unquote clear every single person on
earth when that's your claim,
there can be no uncertainty in your
methods when uncertainty is the one
thing that binds all forms of mental
health.
We don't understand all the ways the
mind works,
probably we never will,
but psychotherapy and psychiatry
functioning within a scientific
community within a code of ethics that
protects from abuse as made advances,
that can help those who are struggling
to cope with life.
It's not perfect,
but it's a hell of a lot better than
scientology.
No.
Hey everybody.
Thank you so much for watching.
You can subscribe to this channel,
but at the bank audible for sponsoring
this episode,
if you don't know,
audible has a gigantic selection of
digital audio books and actually one of
my new year's resolutions for this year
is to read more books and audible is
helping me to do that.
The first book that I read this here was
jd Vance's hillbilly elegy,
which is fantastic,
and jd Vance just recorded his audio
book with his voice on audible.
So if you go to audible.com/nerd
writer,
you can get a free 30 day trial,
but also you get one free audio books,
so I suggest you use it on Hillbilly
Elegy.
I don't think you'll regret it.
I'm also nerd writer t shirts are still
available at [inaudible] dot com.
I'll leave the link in the description
below and I was nominated for a shorty
award,
so if you're interested and you could
vote for me on that,
I'll leave the link below for that too.
Thanks guys for watching.
I'll see everybody next Wednesday.